and now a tale of two americas
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now one of joe biden's main selling
points during the 2020 campaign was that
unlike trump
he had empathy for all americans
especially those who were struggling
joe biden is a fighter for the middle
class joe biden has a plan to put
americans back to work
this is what democrats care about
providing support for american families
who are struggling
voters were telling me i really think
joe biden cares about me
of course that was all a lie he's only
been in office for three weeks but
already under his anti-business policies
like the halting of the keystone
pipeline many of our fellow americans
are being made to suffer now think about
the people
of falk arkansas who until biden came
along were grateful
to have good paying jobs with the
pipeline project
their incomes not only meant that they
could feed their families but also build
their futures
well biden completely upended their
lives with the stroke of a pen
it's hard to make plans when you've got
an administration that's
trying to crush your future this was
going to be your family home for you and
your three boys
i'm not without a job and i don't have a
job
my husband mccully knight and i we were
both going to be able to have the
opportunity to go work on the keystone
to have that future just completely
taken away
just by one signature our youngest
daughter is a junior in high school and
she's supposed to be going to college
too and
i don't know how i'm going to pay for it
as absolutely heartbreaking
biden's keystone decision alone will
kill an estimated 11
000 jobs this year but don't worry
america
all those brand new green jobs biden
promised you
are coming any day now i'm sure is it
that the
administration is going to let the
thousands of
uh fossil fuel industry workers out of
work or will soon be out of work because
of a vitamin eo
when it is and where it is that they can
go for their green job
well i'd certainly welcome you to
present your data of all the thousands
and thousands of people who
won't be getting a green job maybe next
time you're here you can present that
oh jen is that the empathy we were
promised in the biden white house
on just this one issue of keystone
thousands are now
frantically worrying about how they're
going to pay their bills
the biden's team doesn't give a rat you
know what about them
but we know what biden and his handlers
do care about
catering to their rich donors and
enriching their sleazy family members
compare the fortunes of the keystone
families to joe's son hunter
well the keystone workers have work
experience and relevant skills
but hunter with zero talent or relevant
skills
was paid millions to sit on the board of
burisma while his dad spearheaded
obama's ukraine efforts
he cashed in on the biden name which he
readily admitted
if your last name wasn't biden do you
think you would have been asked to be on
the board of burisma
i don't know i don't know probably not i
don't think that there's a lot of things
that would have happened in my life that
that if my last name wasn't fine
well how lucrative is is it to be a
biden well lucrative enough to pay for a
25
000 a month luxury home rental in venice
california
no sign that he in fact he's so brazen
about not being held accountable for his
business dealings
that he remains heavily invested in a
joint venture with companies owned by
the chinese communist party
are we supposed to feel better though
because he's now working to unwind his
business relationship
with america's most powerful global
adversary now imagine if this is one of
the trump kids
you know what the reaction would be well
i'm sure we'll have all these questions
answered
answered though in hunter's new memoir
he just landed a two million
dollar advance for a new book deal with
simon schuster
do you think one of those keystone
workers could land a book deal for a
fraction of that advance
of course not by the way joe's brother
frank is living large too he's literally
using his close relationship with his
brother
to drum up clients in a newspaper ad
the two biden brothers have long held a
commitment to
to pushing environmental issues my
brother is a model
for how to go about doing his work and
the ad very subtly
references the biden reputation
oh god now even the president's
son-in-law is trying to leverage the
biden name
on the covet issue no less unbelievable
well biden should launch another 100-day
challenge i just came up with this
i ask all americans to name a biden
family member
who isn't somehow compromised
well this country and this government
are supposed to belong
to the american people all the people
remember that language from the
gettysburg address
government of by and for the people
not just the well-connected people not
the rich people not the people with
supporters in the media
not the people with connections to
foreign dictators no
all the people the trump administration
fought for the sort of people who worked
on the keystone pipeline
but to joe biden and his team most
americans are racists
who are destroying the planet to the
biden team
our working people are disposable and
dispensable
meanwhile the folks with connections
they're buried in benjamin's
under the bide administration the
privileged few
biden's family wall street plutocrats
big tech billionaires and hard left
special interest groups like blm
they're going to get paid big that's not
compassionate
it's not caring it's cruel cronyism
and heartless indifference to the
working people of this country
sadly this is what americans voted for
last november
this is what georgians voted for in
january
and until we can vote again this is what
we're going to get
a tale of two societies of average
americans
scrambling to stay afloat while the
elites such as biden's friends and
family
enjoy the high life but we get to vote
again in less than two years
and the more americans watch this
two-tiered economy
the less they're going to like it and
that's the angle